[Music]
how was your day
um my day my day sweetheart would you
take your hat off the team please
you look so cute
hey what are you doing down there
cleaning up some beer can you get done
would you help me try to host up here
well no actually i think i'm gonna stay
down here for a little while i know that
man's got a fun jawline he's just
well i'm sorry you're upset well yeah
i'm upset well you know what i should
give you more notice all right but i was
a little bit busy i know i know your job
is really stressful tammy you know what
honey i'm doing it all right i threw the
party for over 100 people in in two days
time i did it with no help and i'm
cleaning up after your football stars
who by the way happen to be pigs i'm
doing it but i'm not gonna pretend to
like it not right now not down here when
i go back up there i'll give you a big
smile all right just like i know you
need but down here i am pissed
and i'm going to stay down here until i
can get back up there and give you your
smile
when you're done down here it'd be
really great if you'd come up and help
me host
to talk to her yep
and
i am contrary to popular opinion i'm
very good communicating with women folk
sweetheart
that is ridiculous
what time is it
you know you and i have the exact same
amount of experience being parents
we've been doing this job the
same
number of years and months and days as
each other and the truth of it is that
we just don't have any control
you know for the most part we're just
winging it
and i'm you know i don't know what to do
i don't know what to do in this
situation
but i'll tell you what the most
important thing to me
is that my daughter be able to talk to
me
a girl is entitled
to that with her mother
my mother used to tell me that i was
going to go to hell if a guy ever even
touched me and you know that didn't work
and i'm sure as hell not going to do
that to julie
[Music]
and we raised a smart
responsible
moral girl
and i have faith in us
and i faith in her
you know we just gotta let her go
i'm sorry if i hurt you
huh
what i don't know that's why i'm i don't
how do you know me what is it
i've been thinking about something today
i'm gonna make a proposal to you and i
don't want you to jump to any kind of
immediate decision out of it
okay
i've been thinking that um
julie and i could maybe stay here until
she graduates from high school
that would give her some closure here
it would allow me to continue my work
here with the kids
dylan and austin aren't that far away
from each other i mean it's not a long
commute you could go and take the job in
austin
it's not ideal but it's a way that we
could continue our lives keep this
family together
no
just no
yes no
there's no way you just can't say just
know and i'll tell you why it's not
going to happen because that commute
between dylan and us is not just a
simple commute that's a separation
between this family you know what you
know what i need you to just think about
it i'm thinking about i'm listening i
thought about it well i think we need to
start to consider this now from the
perspective of three people in this
family and you and i have a solid
relationship we have a mature
relationship we are mature people and i
know that our relationship can handle it
well you know what no in that sense i'm
not mature i'm not mature i can't handle
that because that's not a relationship
that's not a family that's not what this
family's going to do and as far as those
three people you're leaving one person
out that would be me because i don't
agree with this at all i do not agree
with in any bit of what you've said you
know what i'm thinking about right now
i'm thinking about how bad i'm gonna
feel leaving these kids here why is this
happening honey
i need you to hear me here i hear you
what i'm doing here what you said i did
this thing with tyra understand what
you're saying these kids need me
something
and there are other kids
these kids need me here i would feel bad
to leave
can't you understand that
i love you
[Music]
i respect you
i am proud of you
i am in love with you completely
you all right babe
yeah
i saw that news came out
hell i tried talking to these kids kids
don't understand
you're a good man babe
honey
i gotta tell you something that i've
been needing to tell you all day and
i just haven't haven't been able to and
it's the work this is the worst timing
and i'm sorry about that
and we haven't talked about this in a
long time and i just don't know how
you're gonna take it
[Music]
pregnant like you're gonna have a baby
pregnant
at me in the eye and tell me that
okay
we're gonna have a baby honey you look a
little peaked
[Laughter]
come here
oh
[Music]
love you
i love you
[Music]
hey
the yes gets passed
[Music]
okay
that's right
[Music]
welcome to the family
so i just got asked out to happy hour
from the teachers at school really
can't get any support from any of these
teachers can't get him to sign up for my
mentoring workshop none of that but oh
come on to happy hour where's the happy
hour rivers hey rivers is a great place
you know what i'm gonna go to happy hour
you should and i'm gonna create some
allegiances so maybe i can get some help
over there you should do that rivera's
is a happy place you start having
cocktails everyone will talk about
everything it's easier to get flies
with honey than it is vinegar
oh no that is our daughter's bed are you
crazy that is disgusting
tammy
hey honey you know i wanted to talk to
you about what you said about us not
being east coast people i mean you know
how much i love texas i love it here so
much but we will never know if we're not
eating supposed to be protected we've
got a really big problem we can always
come back we have got a much bigger
problem than what you're talking about
what matt sarason asked your daughter to
marry him
julie
what are you talking about no gracie yes
julie came into my office today and he
asked for julie's hand in marriage he
asked me for her hand in marriage he had
the decency to come talk to you no he
didn't have any decency to come talk to
me because he already talked to her and
you know what your daughter said your
daughter said yes
oh yes
no yes yeah yes yes they're too young
that's what i see hey honey what'd you
tell them i said oh great let's break
out some champagne this is gonna be
fantastic
i don't know why you're yelling at me
i think we agree on this
[Music]
you ready to go home
yeah let's go
[Music]
you